in true marvel fashion captain Marvel's
casters packed with fan favorite actors
alongside them is up-and-coming star
Jimmy Chan playing Star Force member
Minerva Shan has written through the
ranks of British television and film
before appearing in a few worldwide
blockbusters he is what you spotted
there over the years
in 2009 Chan scored a first major credit
by appearing in a special episode of
Doctor Who alongside the popular tenth
the doctor played by David Tennant the
waters of Mars which won a Hugo Award is
set on the red planet in 2050 9 where
the doctor encounters a human colony
which is endangered by his presence Chan
plays Mia Bennet's
a geologist who survives the doctors and
intentional meddling with a structure of
time chan didn't have a lot of screen
time for the episode which was one of
Tennant's final outings as the doctor
was well-received setting her up for
more roles in the future a popular
British sitcom the aired for four series
from 2006 to 2010 the IT crowd revolved
around three main characters each of
whom brings different neuroses to their
roles as tech support for a major
company Shan appeared in two different
episodes as two different characters
after a brief initial appearance in the
2010 episode the final countdown she
reappeared in Wrentham vs. random that
same year playing a female Sulu in a
Star Trek parody Chan followed up this
appearance with a role in the BBC series
Sherlock which stars Benedict
Cumberbatch and Martin Freeman as Holmes
and Watson respectively the hit show
formats each classic Arthur Conan Doyle
story about the famous detective in two
long installments that deliver a modern
twist on the tale Chan appeared in the
2010 episode the blind banker a suelen
Yao a Chinese pottery expert working at
a museum who disappears and turns out to
have a dark past some things are
supposed to sit behind glass they're
made to be touched to be handled
after smaller films and some guest spots
Chan finally found a few recurring roles
on television shows cementing herself as
a star on the rise after her appearance
on Sherlock in 2011 Chan scored a series
regular role in the fourth series of
Secret Diary of a cool girl which was
broadcast in both the UK and the US
starring Billie Piper best known for her
companion role alongside David Tennant
on Doctor Who the show centered on
Hannah a normal London girl by day who
works as a call girl at night to pay her
bills as her two lives continue to
collide she meets new girls at the
agency at which she is employed
that's where Chan comes in during the
fourth season of the show she played
Charlotte a haughty escort working for
the agency who has strident and always
gets what she wants
Chan followed up this huge role with a
regular spot on bedlam a British sci-fi
drama drawing the show's second series
starring Theo James bedlam tells a story
of bedlam Heights a rundown complex of
apartments home to a series of strange
hauntings Chan appeared as Kira a
childhood friend of a character from the
first series who serves as a confidante
for LA the de-facto lead of the second
series paramedic some fun really game
mix Chan's first blockbuster breakout
came in jack ryan shadow recruit in 2014
she appeared alongside Chris Pine as a
namesake CIA agents Kevin Costner as a
CIA official who recruits him director
Kenneth Branagh as a Russian tycoon and
Keira Knightley as a medical students
and Ryan's fiance sham played Amy Chang
a fellow spy on Ryan's team who proves
herself to be an incredibly competent
ally an extension of the Harry Potter
universe fantastic beasts and where to
find them was released to eager fans in
2016
moving the magical world from the UK to
the United States during the 1920s the
movie introduces audiences to Newt
Scamander
played by Oscar winner Eddie Redmayne
imagine a ologist Chan played Madame
yojo a member of the International
Confederation of wizards
you know which of your creatures was
responsible
appreciated that the film was a
commercial smash grossing a total of
eight hundred and fourteen million
dollars and was hailed by most critics
as a promising start to a new franchise
within the already wildly popular world
of harry potter though Chan did not
appear in the 2018 sequel her role in
such a massive blockbuster set erupted
for even more film success chum returned
to a regular television role in humans a
British series for channel 4 the aired
between 2015 and 2018 and was also
broadcast on the American Network AMC
based on a Swedish show called real
humans the series featured a world
filled of hyper-realistic robots called
since sham played a synth hired by a
human family to work as a nanny peralta
three seasons on the show chanced and
our performance attracted plenty of
positive attention
Chan's biggest role yet came in 2018 s
crazy rich Asians the breakout hit
adapted from Kevin Kwan's best-selling
novel of the same name as the first film
since 1993 said Joy Luck Club to feature
an all-asian cast and an Asian American
lead the film was both the critical and
the commercial success Chan played
Astrid a fabulously rich and impeccably
accomplished socialite who was so
successful in worldly that a husband
thus grown resentful thanks to the first
film's success two sequels are already
in the works and a mid-credits scene
indicated that one may focus heavily on
Astrid as it shows her locking out of
the mysterious man at a luxurious party
2018 s Mary Queen of Scots is a
historical drama based on the conflict
between cousins Mary and Elizabeth the
first to secure the throne of England
director Josie Rourke staged a soapie
feminist spectacle with some
groundbreaking casting choices including
Chan's role Cham played Bess of Hardwick
a close friend of Elizabeth the first
who not only acted as the Virgin Queens
confidant birth alongside her husband
helped keep Mary captive for 15 years
even though Chan's casting was
technically historically inaccurate
Rourke insisted on colorblind casting
giving chan an opportunity to make a big
impression before her debut in the MCU
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite Marvel characters are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and Ted the bell so you don't
miss a single
one
[Music]
you